brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com hey guys my name is Jess
McDonald it is a fifth of much today and
you're watching games what news
according to series creator Hideo Kojima
metal gear solid 5 display did to be the
final Metal Gear entry in the series
although we have to remember that he
said that about almost every single
Metal Gear sequels so kajima told IGN
that while the series may see future
spin-offs and reboots he's done with
this particular saga explaining I always
say this will be my last Metal Gear but
the games in the series that I've
personally designed and produced metal
gear on MSX mg to MGS 1234 peace walker
and now mgs5 are what constitute a
single metal gear stagger with metal
gear solid 5 i'm finally closing the
loop on that saga metal gear solid 5 is
the missing link in the saga that will
fill the gap between mgs3 and the 1987
Metal Gear games the phantom pain will
be out on sep tember 1 a new rock band
game is coming so for those of you who
want to turn it up to eleven here is the
details Harmonix has announced that rock
band 4 will come with new music and
it'll arrive on xbox one and ps4 this
year new guitar drums and microphone
peripherals created by Mad Catz will be
supported and Harmonix has said they're
doing their best to support old
controllers as well that is if any of
your old controllers still work and mine
sure don't in a move that has made
everybody happy rock band legacy DLC
which was bought on the ps3 will carry
over to the ps4 and the same goes for
content bought on the Xbox 360 which
will carry over to the xbox one Harmonix
have also made it clear that this will
be the last rock band game and update
will carry the series on from here it
was announced that elite dangerous was
set to be console exclusive to the Xbox
one but frontier developments have come
out to confirm that it is only going to
be a timed exclusive the game will be
arriving on Xbox one later
this year and although it's already out
on pc frontier said it was difficult
deciding to go with xbox one exclusively
at launch executive david Braben
explained the xbox audience have been
very good to us we've sold quite a few
xbox games with Microsoft we also had a
launch title for Xbox one so our tools
and technology has been battle-hardened
on Xbox one ready as you can imagine
this set people off as it sounded like
the PlayStation users would miss out but
braven later tweeted that elite
dangerous would eventually arrive on ps4
it's unclear how long this exclusivity
period will last but braven added that
the game is also slated to arrive on Mac
let me know down in the comments if you
reckon metal gear solid 5 is actually
going to be the last metal gear game you
can head to gain spot where we've got
news on wasteland 2 coming to consoles
and valves overcoming VR motion sickness
that's all the good stuff I've got be
today but do you remember that tomorrow
I'll have my top five stories up the
whole gaming week all ready to go so I
hope to see you then